have you ever wanted to know how
healthcare companies deal with large
amount of data coming from multiple
different sources well i've been really
curious how our insurance claims lab
reports and other data is put to use so
today i invited a care vp of engineering
from veda health a really cool
healthcare startup creating a
personalized experience for patients
welcome amul and thanks for joining us
today thanks priyanka looking forward to
this chat
awesome so tell us more about vida
health yeah so if i was to describe beta
in one sentence or one line it would be
that we're a digital health virtual care
company and we
connect both mind and body programs into
a single platform
a lot of companies that you see out are
often treating patients for one
condition
and our platform actually supports
multiple different conditions so
it really helps people when they can go
to just one single place and get
different kinds of treatment on a single
play platform well awesome so it sounds
like there are three different types of
customers there are the individuals like
us who may need the help and then there
are health plans and then you have the
employers who are helping
so let's double click on that a little
bit uh what are the challenges you
actually set out to solve for these
three customers so as you can see um we
have a lot of different kinds of data
that's coming in and we have to connect
all of that stuff together in a seamless
manner and we have to host this in you
know we have services that are mobile
focused but there are services that are
for web uh on the back end and so it's a
pretty uh interesting challenge and i'm
glad that we've consolidated everything
on google now awesome so um ease of use
is definitely one that you're pointing
out as to as the reason to choose google
cloud are there any others yeah as i
looked at you know when was when we were
evaluating google cloud really there
were three big areas that came to me uh
as like
reasons why why consolidating in gcp was
great
one was just the cost reduction because
you know after consolidating everything
it's just one nice single place where
you can drive efficiency and we've
already seen somewhere around like 50
reduction in in in cost just by
bringing everything in one place right
you can optimize fine-tune different
things the other thing i would say was
more around you know developer
productivity because now engineers don't
have to worry about where to deploy and
kind of keep that cognitive
overload much more lower because they
it's one single place that they know how
to look at and monitor uh so they're
happy
and if they're happy they're more
productive right and then the final
piece i would say is that we had already
made a lot of investments in big query
and
ai and ml um so
combining all these data sources in one
place and bringing even things like
google workspace has proven to be very
effective for us to and it opened up
uh a lot of interesting new product
ideas that we were not uh thinking of
before or not possible before what are
some of the challenges you're solving
with machine learning and data analytics
you know we are trying to
you have three or four different areas
of investment in machine learning and
data data science today
uh part of the area that we focus on is
how do we make our providers we
internally call it making a provider
superhuman
so building tools and assistive
technologies that can help providers
become much more efficient at how they
do their jobs
as an example you know using
note taking automatic note taking so
because we are
we have the audio and video conversation
that's going on part of the job after a
concert is for someone to actually write
down the notes for for with the patient
uh but what if like using nlp and speech
to text we are able to just take down
those notes for you so that's one area
where you know we reduce the amount of
burden on the providers so that way they
can treat more patients in in some ways
and then you know another area where
we've tried to help providers is also
how can we
make their case
get get them more patients without
burdening them uh too much so as an
example
depending on the severity and the
acuity of the patient
how can we surface those patients much
uh quickly to our providers and maybe
there's others who are doing already
very well they don't need that much
attention how do you prioritize that
caseload so those are a couple of
applications that we've seen on the
provider side where machine learning has
been very useful um in in surfacing this
information much more quickly to our
providers
from our conversation earlier i do
recall widapedia which is another major
recommendation platform that you built
with data from workspace and bigquery
now what is it and uh how does it work
yeah well first of all let me
explain what vidapedia is right even
without machine learning
um so it's a set of protocols it's uh
basically you can think of them as like
google docs that have been written
that
help our providers and our clinicians
uh follow a protocol when certain things
happen over time our
medical organization you know mike
scahiluser he sort of created a corpus
of like almost 150 200 protocols that
help people know what is the right level
what is the right thing to do and what's
the right care to give in in a
particular situation and now as you can
imagine
no human is able to store 200 different
sort of protocols in their head at the
same time it becomes a data access
problem right like how do you quickly
get access to this sort of information
at high speed and so what vidapedia
recommendation system does on machine
learning is actually we've kind of
indexed all those documents and then we
look at what patients are what is the
patient provider interaction that's
going on and then surface the right
protocol for a given interaction right
so
if during the course of this chat
interaction
the machine learning model detects that
this
triggers you know a particular protocol
then it surfaces that to the provider
during the session or even after the
session and so then what happens is the
provider is able to
you know give the right care to the
patient and so from our point of view
the provider becomes more efficient at
the same time increasing the level of
quality of like the care that they're
providing so the team is pretty excited
about that and we wouldn't have been
able to do this if we were not able to
connect
what the google doc
protocols look like from google
workspace
take that data and index it and store it
in bigquery and then be able to build
machine learning tools on top of that
right and so you can see pretty quickly
by going to google uh one of the things
we've been able to nicely connect is
that the google workspace data that our
providers use to our actual service um
which is the machine learning algorithms
and build it build a product that's in
my opinion something pretty unique uh
that you know we when we set out to do
uh move to google we had not even
thought about this but now that it's
there it just makes applications like
this actually possible for us
yeah that is so amazing to hear because
it's it is one of those unique aspects
of using google cloud uh because
workspace data is right there and you
can just put it into bigquery and start
to do stuff with it uh now obviously
this whole workflow is pretty data
intensive and this is an architecture
show so let's dive into the details what
does the data pipeline flow look like
and what are the data sources involved
and how is it making its way through the
tools to
making it useful in these machine
learning use cases that you just talked
about so we ingest data from variety of
different sources all the way at the
beginning where you know our health
plans might send us eligibility files or
they might send us you know claims data
that tell us a little bit more about the
member then the members themselves will
often bring their own devices into the
system so for instance they might have a
fitbit and they might connect that with
the vita app so now you're getting to
see you know the steps that they're
taking or the weight or whatever log
whatever they are logging in that
for diabetes patients sometimes we ship
out glucometers and so then you get to
see
you know their their sugar readings and
and stuff like that so all of data is
getting ingested some of it is real time
some of it is batched um and and it's
we're collecting all of this stuff from
from different then even on the provider
side the providers are conducting
consoles and they're taking notes for
those consoles right so that's another
piece of data that gets ingested into
all of this stuff and the the goal of
this data platform is at the end of the
day you know uh help derive insights and
make decisions on top of that right and
so you know our goal was to
uh create a system that's seamless where
everything gets stored in one place like
bigquery um and then derive in sets
build build tools on top of that so um
it's it's not just bigquery data which
is sort of uh somewhat unstructured but
also structured data and relational data
that we get from postgres
and mysql
all of that ultimately lands in bigquery
for us and then
applications get built on top of that
right so our analysts work on
tools visualization tools like
data studio and looker and
our data scientists
uh build on top of the bigquery data to
build machine learning models and and
connect that to our actual services
right um one of the
things that we've kind of recently
gotten
used uh or started exploring is how can
we use vertex ai for quickly building
these models and deploying them like you
know in one of our recent hackathons one
of the most impressive things about this
this tool was that even like uh non
i would say machine learning engineers
are able to quickly use vertex ai to try
out an experiment and see if if that
might be useful uh so i'm pretty excited
about uh the the sort of seamless
integration of the ingest as well as
like the analysis engine that we're
building on top of that that is so cool
to hear because we just launched it
recently right at io and we have an
entire series of vertex ai uh videos
that i've been working on and we would
link those below so thanks for the
mention on vertex ai and how easy it has
made to uh to use the to apply machine
learning to any sort of data and make
the steps um easier and accessible to
everybody
now um i'm curious about the
transformations uh so you talked about
where you're storing the data and a lot
about machine learning um there must be
some sort of transformations happening
what are you using for data
transformation yeah today we have i mean
in the past uh we've been we're writing
a lot of custom etl pipelines um we've
learned that you know managing them
making them monitoring them
keeping them sort of stable and running
has has been a challenge and being a
small team just like we try and find
ways to do managed services on google
we've tried to explore what are other
tools available out there and we've
settled on dbt as as the you know the
transformation
tool that we plan to currently use um
for transforming some of this data as we
move it from one system to another or
get it ready for analysis and and stuff
okay so there's a lot happening
obviously there's there's data ingestion
then transformation and then there's
machine learning on top of that how do
you manage all of this stuff in a
pipeline how do you orchestrate this
pipeline well i mean in this case the
answer is pretty simple i think we just
use cloud composer for orchestrating the
pipeline
scheduling all of this ingest processing
there and running all of that stuff so
again um having these tools ready and
and be seamlessly working well with
bigquery is you know beneficial for us
and i think the team has sort of taken
that up and and implemented them in it
all right so when it comes to healthcare
it's important to address the elephant
in the room obviously security right
so let's talk a little bit about
high-level security requirements uh that
you have to look for in designing this
system uh so you're right i don't
actually think of it as even the
elephant in the room it's just like
always there and actually one of the
reasons that i forgot to mention
uh when we initially talked about why
what was the advantage of going to
google is that
you know in the old system that we had
we had these two different cloud
providers that we were working on
and one of the fundamental things with
security is like what is your surface
area and we've had a lot of data flowing
between one and one system to the other
that creates you know that opens us up
for you know um
so you know higher surface area where
someone can something can go wrong and
people can get access to it so
because the patient data that we have we
work on is fairly sensitive we have to
be extremely careful of protecting it
the privacy laws around this are pretty
stringent um so actually moving to
google has been
beneficial in in that sense because
first of all we are a small company as a
startup and so i always tell everyone
like you know i would rather just use
google as my shield you have thousands
of engineers in at google who are
thinking
uh
living and breathing constantly thinking
about security and how to secure the
google cloud environment and so just
being part of that whole ecosystem helps
us um immensely where we don't have to
worry about our own
uh you know security thing as long as we
follow the best practices that google
lays out uh for us
and you know i think we are uh we also
sort of combining that with like the
google workspace side of stuff right
where you can enable things like data
loss protection
uh we can mask pii data all of these
things just become instantly available
to us and we don't have to spend a lot
of our
mental sort of capacity to think and
evaluate what what we need to do it also
helps us with our customers right
because people are more likely to
believe when we tell them like hey we've
used and turned on whatever google is um
is doing in this space um also with our
health plans for instance they are often
looking for
a vote of confidence or you know they're
kind of saying hey what cloud vendor are
you using and when you tell them that
you you're on google they're often
pretty satisfied with the fact that you
know if it's a big company like that is
sort of uh taking care of the security
we kind of i call it bum drafting behind
a big
you know company like that no it's
extremely helpful because you know a lot
of the times we think that going
multi-cloud or having things in hybrid
cloud is um is good but then especially
in this case when it comes to security
um it's it's a little bit like like you
said reducing your surface area of
attack is is the most important thing to
think about now we talked a lot about
the data analytics and machine learning
architecture
i want to pivot a tiny bit and learn
more about the application architecture
itself now how is the web app set up the
compute the database i assume it's all
normal standard stuff but would love to
hear about that as well because we did
this migration fairly recently right we
moved from a different cloud vendor to
google we were able to work with our
google partner to sata and really
use some of the best practices that that
are and modern practices that that are
available to us right and so
it's not very surprising it's like a
standard you know um i would say a
three-tier architecture you have like
load balancers at the at the front just
deployed in kubernetes engine google
kubernetes engine
and then a middle sort of api layer that
returns like a whole bunch of
request response and at the end you have
a postgres database right and so
architecturally it's not that complex
simple is good it's easy to scale
especially on google so you know for me
that's been the great thing even even
the database is like moved over to not
like our own customs or a postgres thing
but on gcs postgres and that way
uh scaling of database which use used to
be a you know big discussion point and
debate it just becomes like a few clicks
of a button and you can now vertically
scale a database if you want so well you
mentioned a little bit about migration
how did you go about doing that so i
worked with the
google so support team that i have will
um who i work with pretty closely
and you know we kind of
knew that i had made up my mind that we
wanted to consolidate our our
cloud system into one place and google
was a choice and so with will we kind of
evaluated a few different partners that
could help us do the migration
uh ended up choosing sata for a few
different reasons i think they're pretty
well known in the industry part of the
major sort of migration plan here was
around how do we
transfer all of the data that was in the
other cloud system
have minimum downtime for our for our
customers
and then also
how do we make sure we set up this new
system in a much more modern and you
know easy to deploy uh way so that our
in engineers going forward can take
ownership of that system and be able to
sort of continuously deploy in in the
system we probably worked for about a
quarter quarter and a half to come up
with the entire plan end to end they
wrote some of the
they helped us write some of the code
around terraform scripts that can help
us deploy to google and then on the
actual day of migration they also are on
hand to
uh make sure we are orchestrating the
moves sort of together so shutting down
the old system
migrating data and
turning on the new system and sort of
stuff so it was a pretty exciting time
but i'm uh so glad that it went without
a hitch and you know now we're pretty
happy with this system it sounds so cool
to hear the the back story of the
migration right because we just talked
about the architecture which is the
current architecture and then um and
then when you hear the migration story
and all that goes into it and teams like
sata and the google cloud team and your
team combined together like bring bring
the whole thing to life
um this is pretty amazing to hear now
what's next for you guys how are you
planning to augment this existing
architecture
and what else is underway for vida uh
actually now the the
fun part starts from my point of view
because it's all in one place and
you know my
uh
call for the team is now let's double
down even more make more ma use of more
managed services that google offers and
in particular i'm very excited about a
couple of areas which is the google
healthcare api and the fire related
capabilities that google has invested in
right um so
historically fire has not been a very
you know it has not had a lot of
traction it's been
increasing little by little but we've
heard over the last year year and a half
things have moved quite a bit in that
space and
just like we are storing all this
information about medical data
in one in in our own propriety formats
we want to now start using google's uh
fire storage as well to start storing
the data so it's easier to exchange this
sort of information with other networks
outside of veda um so so the classic
example is like you go to a doctor they
refer you to another doctor for some
other reason
you would expect that your data gets
securely and
uh clearly transferred over uh from one
place so that the other doctor doesn't
have to ask you the same thing again or
try and understand what you're trying to
you know what what are they trying to
treat and so the same thing same
challenges are
coming for us as well so if we are
treating someone with a condition that
we are not
that that we currently don't support
right
and we want to refer them out to someone
else we want to be able to create a
system where our data just gets very
seamlessly transferred over to another
doctor's like maybe an inpatient uh
experience as well so this is where i'm
pretty excited about because google
healthcare apis
and the fire capabilities that google is
building on are just you know things are
like where applications can be built on
top of and i don't have to worry about
the protocol layer and how is it stored
and all that you know fun stuff
yeah to store the data let the api do
the thing and just access the api to do
the thing yep well thanks amol it was
awesome to have you on the show well
thanks again for inviting me as well and
i was great to kind of showcase how we
built vida on top of google well we
learned a lot today how to set up a data
pipeline for healthcare systems and the
most amazing part how beautifully the
google workspace data can be combined
with bigquery to create a
recommendations engine well if you're
interested in learning more there's an
entire blog linked below that dives into
the details of how vida held and the
team at our implementation partner sada
brought this architecture to life want
to see more real-life architectures like
this subscribe to get notified
you